more and more people are taking control
of their lives and not simply working
for the man I have sitting next to me
today one among you who certainly knows
what it's like to be the keeper of his
own destiny I would argue that if you're
going out on your own you have to
recognize that it's very difficult to
create your cushion you've got to go
you've got to go all in and and if you
fail you can be Sachin maybe go a
different course but you know a plan B
needs to be in place of what you're
gonna do but you can't be putting energy
towards that because plan a is all about
emotions
I actually thought I was taking one here
I don't even know I actually woke up
early by accident there's no reason and
that was like [ __ ] it and then took a
shower because I woke up a little does
your second charity yes
like even like 11
to be about there we go talk to me about
the most ghetto situation from an operon
I would say our first three or four
years were pretty ghetto
well here's ghetto situation from our
office space we can give me a ghetto
office space story because you couldn't
sleep this is in Tribeca but you
couldn't sleep in the middle because the
lights stayed on all yeah there was a
little little office room that was like
probably 10 feet by 10 feet and it was
the only place that the light wasn't get
into so you have to sleep in there why
do you guys sleep there because it was
nicer than your apartments yeah you're a
true practitioner if you're not a
headline reader cuz you read something
once that said it's not doing well or
some company did poorly with it or your
friend ran 100 bucks worth of ads on
Facebook and said it didn't work if you
got out of being a headline reader and
became a true practitioner you would
know what I and we know which is this is
driving real-life results and very
honestly I have no passion for it and we
have passion for your attention
if you all stop going to your cell phone
in social networks I wouldn't even
remember what it was called these are
not places that are nice to haves or
maybes these are prerequisites for being
relevant at all in 2016 and cannot be 9
minutes of your time it's been really
it's been so fun to watch because there
hasn't been something this big since
Instagram and it got bought by Facebook
so fast yeah that um it's it's kind of
like fun to watch like the first major
platform I mean there's there's not that
many of these there's not that many
things that you can watch everybody like
overtime get on
like it's been a long time since you
know early Facebook early Twitter you
know I do I do I do I think it's I think
it just started Tony I'm taking over
your account promise me you're gonna
promise you didn't make more snaps
promise understand these things are
already at scales that very few things
never get to likes not just already
bigger than tumblr has ever been like
these are like really big platforms and
I think we're also in a different place
with this so like unlike when Twitter
and Facebook did their thing the scale
of the phone is so intense like we used
to do that on our like I used Twitter
for the first two years mainly on
desktop so crazy but I promise you in a
world where this is the communication
not what you think you're doing when
this phone and these channels is the
communication I'd like to follow you on
your eight-hour day I have a funny
feeling there's an hour there that you
could be deploying to learning
make up live right nope if you're a true
bred entrepreneur if you're a true bred
entrepreneur as a journalist as a as a
as a as a pundit as a thinker as a
educator as a social you know
commentator you're different right but
if you're an entrepreneur a purebred
right and you're crying about this
you've already lost okay so quick
question about marketing him do you
understand I understand Porton point
because because it because the market is
way harder then some old white dudes
give any money you know what's crazy
thing you're gonna love this you're
gonna love this how aligned we are ready
I started vaynermedia here I started
running it started by with it I started
I ran it here AJ was super sad because
vaynermedia we raised any money we're
just it's a client service business it
didn't mean any money yeah in here all
the than all the homies are rich on
paper and AJ's like you drag me into
this boat I mean client service sucks
here we are all got [ __ ] up
vaynermedia this shows gonna do a
hundred million revenue all right
brother give me a hug Lizzie yes I get I
love you baby I'll see you soon I think
in the last several years I've been
positioned as a social media expert and
I'll be very honest with you and Frank
TechCrunch audience I don't like that I
don't want to be a guru I don't wanna be
a pun dn't I'm a business operator as a
kid I built this 65 million dollar a
year business without any venture
capital without any M&A activity I'm an
entrepreneur I just I've spent the last
four years building an agency with no
cash infusion from a three to a hundred
million dollar business I'm a
businessman and so I in this book I
talked about how I do that
it's HR it's actually caring about
people its leadership it's having
product vision
I knew in 2009 that people would spend a
hundred thousand dollars a month on
their social media budgets if they were
a big company most people didn't so the
book really covers you know leadership
self-awareness I talk a lot about
emotional intelligence a lot about EQ I
talk about the things that I'm worried
about you know what I'm worried about if
you're watching this TechCrunch if
you're watching this your new
entrepreneurial
Oh system you know what we're not
talking about enough we're not talking
about how hard it is to be an
entrepreneur how few businesses win I
feel a sense of responsibility to talk
about the fact that kids have depression
and even we have kids and grownups
committing suicide in our space because
we're not talking practical enough about
business just cuz you raised money
doesn't mean you're gonna have a
successful business everything you do
will define who you are for life but you
got to work hard and fast and extreme on
a micro level so it's the it's the get
be prepared mentally for a marathon by
running us by running a sprint
day-to-day bro I miss you I miss you so
much
you look so handsome the Internet is
distribution there is no there's no ABC
there's no box there's no Viacom there's
no satellites there's no printing press
there's no there's no Hearst media
there's you know there's the internet
and then on top of the Internet there's
things like Facebook and Instagram but
much like cable television like
unlimited channels if ESPN or Annie and
Bravo come along they become competitors
for that attention and that nap and that
now is musically right like nobody
nobody knows what's going on on
musically but I do and I can tell you
right now in 24 months there's gonna be
people making millions of dollars a year
off of musically and 98% of the readers
had never even thought that they're
gonna read your article had never heard
of it and the 2% I've heard of it it's
only because they have eat the 30 no
girls in their home I've been surprised
by how many people have bought into well
I'm gonna work smart not hard
the people that are winning are doing
both go take a really cold shower I
promise you you're not outsmarting me
the problem is you're just not out
working me so I think the biggest
surprise is how many people think
there's some random system how there's
some crazy algorithm or process that's
gonna create passive income how there's
this like that they're so smart and
that's why they'll be able to have more
time to surf and be on boats and enjoy
their wealth I've been surprised by
people's naivete that hard work isn't
part of the equation